-You broke into something that
you would also think, like
this would maybe not be the wa
your career was heading.
You were in "The Mandalorian."
-Yes.
I was in "The Mandalorian.
-You and Jason Sudeikis.
-Me and "Suds."
-Played Stormtroopers.
-We played Stormtroopers.
Bike scouts, officially.
I don't want to upset
a billion dorks online.
Bike scouts.
Want to make sure I get
my spot at the convention.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, another odd choice.
-But you actually wore the suit.
-We wore the suits.
It was awesome.
I mean, to get to do that
was so cool.
And we, like --
You know, we had bikes
that were, like, on hydraulics
And I punched Baby Yoda.
-You did.
I feel like people
might think that's a joke,
but in this scene, you reall
did punch Baby Yoda.
-Yes. And I can't stress
this enough --
the scene called for it.
-Yeah.
-I didn't -- It wasn't lik
I did it willy-nilly.
-Yeah. It was in the script.
-It was in the script.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But the first time I did it
I hit it, like, too hard,
because I -- I don't know.
I was excited.
So I clocked it.
And like 30 people popped up
like moles in that game
that you hit.
And everyone was like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!"
Whoa!
Whoa!"
And then, like,
Jon Favreau came down
and, like, put me in his,
like, little, like,
nook of his Favreau.
And he went -- He's like, "Tha
thing is very expensive.
You don't want to do that.
He's like, "And I can't
stress this enough.
This is the movies."
I was like, "Got it. I got it.
And I went back.
And, like, everyone
was really awkward
because I had, like,
potentially ruined
a billion-dollar franchise
-Yeah.
-So, like,
no one was saying anything
And so, like, before I got o
my, like, hover bike,
I went, "I just want
everyone to know
that Baby Yoda did say something
anti-Semitic to me."
[ Laughter ]
And, like, I thought that
would, like, clear the air
but, instead, it had that vibe
from, like, when a mechani
is working on your car, an
you're like, "Hey, how long?
And they go, like...
They just stare at you.
And, so, I was like, "Cool
No problem."
I, like, sat on the bike.
I was like, "Wow."
And I, like,
leaned over to Suds,
and before I could say
anything, he went, "Oof!"
-Give it up for Adam Pally
everybody.